almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it there's no
doubt that it's really easy to just
criticize without offering an
alternative and it's also much easier to
see things in retrospect than in advance
now on Twitter more and more people some
in good faith have been saying to me
some are trolls some are acting in good
faith
you know David you're doing a lot of
criticism but what should Donald Trump
have done differently to better deal
with the pandemic so that's what I want
to talk about now now if you want to
just say any hindsight analysis is
worthless
well okay then you can click off and go
somewhere else now but we actually do
have some very specific things to talk
about here so there's the big picture
and then there's the micro first of all
before we even deal with the specifics
now as a general thing Donald Trump
never should have disbanded the pandemic
response team and he never should have
cut funding to the CDC this is what they
are supposed to work on all the time we
don't know when the next pandemic will
hit and from said back when he cut the
pandemic response team said we don't
need to be paying for people that aren't
really needed that aren't really doing
anything right now we now know why they
were needed that pandemic response team
never should have been eliminated now
let's get to the specifics of the here
and now back in December when this
started we now know that inside
government they were already discussing
it immediately at that point you say if
X happens we ban travel if Y happens we
do this you have parameters for when
will you start shutting down travel
based on what takes place instead Trump
didn't do that
we were persistently behind the curve
and despite the fact that he's bragging
about how early he did these things
that's not true okay you also back in
December right away you then figure
out how many masks do we have how many
ventilators do we have how would we
distribute them you probably start
distributing them in early January to be
ahead of the game by mid January there
were already hundreds of cases that's
when you start getting the masks and
ventilators to hospitals instead of
what's happening now which is we don't
know where they are they're not telling
us the truth the president of Mass
General here in Massachusetts is asking
people to start 3d printing masks at
home and Trump and pence daily just sort
of stumble around about we're mobilizing
this resource we are bringing this
online we are requesting production
everything happened four to five weeks
late early January
you immediately ask private industry
which Trump loves he loves private
industry he always talks about it you
immediately go to private industry and
you say develop a rapid test now and
also develop an antibody test we are not
using an antibody test here in the
United States this is important to
figure out who has already had it so
many people now believe they had mild
cases of this imagine if we could know
that just hypothetically 5% of the
population has already had this and has
recovered mild or asymptomatic cases
it's really important to know that we
don't have an antibody test you could
have months ago pushed private industry
to develop that and now and also you
immediately say let's start testing
treatments now so instead of now
wondering would chloroquine and as a
thorough Meissen work is it safe
what about Ave again what about room des
vir you start doing that in late January
early February Trump said to Anthony
Fauci over the weekend wouldn't you have
liked to have had two more months on
this you could have had them we are
eight to ten weeks behind on just about
all of this stuff at this point in time
also by late January you got to shut
down the China flights Trump didn't do
it until February you can also I you
absolutely
Trump's clueless and appointing pence
late is idiocy in January you bring on a
kovetz our I would suggest
Ronald claimed this was Obama's Ebola
czar would be look him up on Twitter
that would have been a great person to
appoint and realistically you do the
Europe flight bans in February instead
of March 12th Trump didn't do it until
March 12th very very late by the end of
February
you need a national stay-at-home order
it may be coming eventually we don't
know every day lost is a tragedy here in
Massachusetts we got not a shelter in
place but guidelines about no school
take out only at restaurants etc we got
that on March 15th starting the 17th
every day you lose but we see how it
affects the curves and Trump doing that
at the end of February would have really
prevented a lot of what we're now
dealing with also you have to negotiate
the economic side right the deal every
day they say we're figuring out how to
get money to people we're figuring out
how to bail out industry we're figuring
out how to deal out small business
they're still arguing about the
specifics and nothing has happened yet
who knows when anybody might get money
now you have to get that going in
advance and have it ready being ahead of
the game but we have a system of
government we have a moronic person at
the top and we have an economic system
quite frankly that doesn't work in this
way it's reactive instead of proactive
it's gotten very very ugly let me know
what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman I also want to tell you because
we're all hopefully staying at home what
we've rescheduled the David Pakman show
viewer chess tournament it's this
Wednesday night March 25th at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern okay there will be information
about how to play on social media
anybody can play regardless of your
skill level the tournament will be on
Leach s org that's Li Ches org
all you have to do is get an account on
Leach s org I invite you participate in
the David Pakman show chess tournament
this Wednesday evening March 25th at
8:00 p.m.